oh yeah what's up everybody welcome to
your finger podcast
[Music]
lady Jung we quarantine him with Griffin
[Music]
[Applause]
whoa
[Music]
[Music]
once again my delicious theme song and
still going strong hey everybody welcome
back to we're from with Griffin this is
solo quarantine episode I guess
everybody's doing them can't have a
guest over so I'm doing it by myself
I just hope everybody's safe out there
and you know it's been a week I don't
know how long this has been this is like
quarantine day five or six for me it's
crazy you know it's crazy times out
there I think people are going mad you
know like you know people are singing
imagine on Instagram like crazy people
it's just funny how serious they're
taking it that's what really cracks me
up about that but you know it is what it
is people are trying to find their way
you know you just cooped up in the house
you know it's weird it's challenging
relationships you know what I'm saying
like if you're like I'm just you know
I'm real serious with my girl but like
we're now she's here with me and it's
just like we're learning how it is 24
hours a day with somebody and it could
be challenging for all of us out there
so you know and it's okay to have
whatever feelings you have by the way if
you were feeling bad you're feeling good
you're feeling depressed you're feeling
sad these are normal feelings we don't
know what the hell's going on in the
world right now we don't know if they're
close to finding of a vaccine you know
we can't get real any real information
seems to be politicized like we don't
know what's going on like it's China
telling us the truth that there's no
more viruses being spread there they
haven't had any new cases is that but
then you look at CNN and they're like
you can't believe what they're saying
and then you find out something's going
on and you know Japan wasn't testing you
know then we can't get enough tests here
I mean it's really crazy what's
happening right now this is
unprecedented I've never experienced
anything like this in my life you know
and I'm gonna entertainment business you
know entertainment business is usually a
foolproof through everything Wars
through all kinds of stuff you know
people still need to entertainment but
now we're in a situation where like if
you're a stand-up comedian and this is
like your business this is like your
livelihood you like everyone else who
can't go out and do their job we
for real hey go out and do our job like
we like we can't go on planes to go to
like places that have 250 plus people in
a room we can't be there I mean it's
just it's not safe so right now our
business is shut down and we I don't
know where it's gonna be in the
foreseeable future for me thank God you
know here's podcasting this is great so
I can still bring you guys content I'm
gonna be doing Skype calls with people
um I have a girl on just who knows what
we got to do we just got to do like this
to keep bringing you entertainment you
know also just to stay connected with
the people right this is like the thing
like just to stay connected you know
like I find myself calling people and
people are calling me who I've never
talked to on the phone before or even
wanted to talk to on the phone before
that's why I don't like those people
it's just that you know we live in a
time where we don't talk to people but
now it's like yo we're giving people a
call I think the funny part about it is
you know you're like when you're not
answering your phone
you're clearly saying to somebody I
don't want to talk to you right now I
just don't want to talk to you because
you home what you telling me but you now
everybody's home so if you're not
answering the call it's like a clear
sign like hey guess what don't call me
I'm not trying to talk to you right now
but you know it's just it's just very
interesting I wish there was more facts
of me I don't know anything about it I
don't know enough about it and I don't
know if I can trust what I see online
you know you know and then personally
for me it's like you know I've talked
about my mom you know my mom's got
dementia and it's just you know she's
she gets it but doesn't get it like she
wants to go how she wants to go see you
know a relative that's not alive anymore
and she's like I can I go over there so
it's like you know I I I feel for all
those people out there who are dealing
with that who are dealing with like and
then you know a loved one in that age
group that is really susceptible to
getting this it's like a dangerous age
level that's where my parents are so I'm
really worried about them and then like
you hear about these people that of that
certain age you know they're dying alone
if they contract it they have to be
isolated and then no one can visit them
and they're just sitting there waiting
to die I mean just it's just a nightmare
and I feel for anybody out there in that
situation right now so that's
you know these people who are out in the
beach and these young people who were
just like just being young I'm not gonna
get on him for being just being young
and dumb and selfish because that's when
you are you're in your early 20s you
know you you know you're in college you
know you've been planning a trip and
here you are and now you can't do the
thing that you wanted to do and you feel
it selfish like oh I'm not getting sick
and but you don't understand it like you
could be a carrier that you could be
carrying it to other people that's what
it is you know no you don't want to get
me or your older parents and then you
don't even know that you're sick and
you're getting them sick and then they
die because of that
you know is it worth you know spring
break you know it's crazy and just think
of all like just how the entertainment
business just entertainment business
alone how its shut down like productions
of shut down you know all the shows have
shut down look at sports man look like
the NBA like I had clipper tickets and
now I'm wondering what you know we even
see the NBA again this season like or
how long forget two seasons like how
long before we're actually gonna see the
NBA again who knows we'll be able to
with like who I don't know if I want to
watch it was like nobody in the stands
maybe they'll do it in a gym or
something like is that part of what
makes it fun is like watching it like
it's fun like you're watching people
play in front of a bunch of people I
don't know man so like that pretty sucks
and then like I kind of feel weird like
I'm watching ESPN every day like I watch
your first take with Steven Naismith and
Max Kellerman you know when they're
doing business as usual you know they're
talking about football free agency and
all this stuff and it's just kind of
weird to me to think that like I guess
it's like wishful thinking it's hopeful
thinking that hey by the time football
seasons come this will be all normal
we'll be back to normal but we need a
chance that we won't be back to normal
for a few months and then what happens
like are those teams practicing or
they've been told to stay at home like
when is it gonna be a nationwide
everybody stay at home and then what
will that do for sports you know I'm
just talking about sport in particular
but of course I care about everybody you
know everybody's suffering but you know
I'm just this is content for me I'm just
talking about the things that I see
that's going on and I just feel like
just that aspect of it
shows you how the rippling effects of
that I'm saying because you know you
know you talk about the Sports Arena
forget the players you know the people
that make the most money and they'll be
able to survive for years without having
to work but there's all those stadium
workers there's all those people that
work in the back the underbelly of what
makes things work the parking people and
you know even those crazy dudes outside
who were like hey you got tickets you
got tickets I've selling tickets buying
tickets like what are they doing right
now you know I mean they're gonna be
selling like corona tests maybe you know
coronavirus test you got a test I got a
test you got extra tests you know
something like that but you know at this
point right now I don't know so just
think about all the people that's
involved there and the net extrapolate
that to like the TV revenue so then you
got the TV revenue and that's generated
by like you know Nike and all these kind
of companies and all those places are
shut down so it's like you know it's
like a ripple effect and like and how
will it restart you know so I just see
supports as being like a thing so I
don't know if the NFL's gonna come back
you know they keep they keep talking
like it is and I just think it's I hope
it's I hope it happens but it feels like
this wishful thinking so and then you
know II like I'm an LA person I'm in LA
you know so the Clippers like of course
when the Clippers are favored to win the
championship favorite at least get to
the championship to be in the top three
teams this happens man dude as a clipper
fan I feel super shitty you know what
and I also feel bad for like LeBron
James you know just as a side like just
to keep things light right now you know
I'm it's heavy but I just want to keep
some things light just think about this
guy you know he's like about to retire
he's like three three years away from
not being elite anymore and he's like
really about to do something special
maybe take today goes to the
championship and boom so who knows
thinking he won't be the same player in
nine months ten months who knows so you
know that it's like those are the kind
of little things that have like all
these you know ripple effects from
what's happening right now you know and
then people are getting on the the
president you know I don't know if he's
doing a good job or not in terms of this
I think I think it was just all wishful
thinking I hate to think that there's
politics involved in the kind of
information that is being put out that
the things that people are saying you
know about the virus and how bad or good
it is or where we are in the progress
and and these estimations of like a
hundred million people are gonna get it
and all these kinds of things and then
trying to make sure not everybody gets
it at once and to get you know so I
don't know the information that's being
put out of the White House if this is
you know a hundred percent accurate
orphans for our benefit not to know
everything I mean I just don't know it's
just weird times right now you know it
really is weird times never experienced
anything like this in my lifetime I'm
good everybody I've been doing good I
was sick like months ago just like I had
a bad sinus infection it was affecting
everything my voice and I naturally get
that every year and like we're coming up
on cold and flu season so it's like what
it like it's like if anybody even just
has a cold it's crazy you can't even be
near people like you go outside and you
uh you you you talk to somebody you know
somebody sneezes and they act like
somebody called grenade you don't mean
or if you clear your throat or anything
like that so it's like it's best if we
just keep away from everybody right now
I mean though that's just a message that
everybody's given but like I just saw
that thing about those kids on the beach
and I just like it just to bring it up
again I saw them and they were just
talking just like kids you know like you
know we've been planning this for weeks
and you know damn dude you know get out
of there like oh look at me though I
shaved my mustache you know I'm just
right now bringing it up this is how
crazy my [ __ ] is right now I shaved cut
my hair you know I don't cause what else
what does it do then people are like oh
you mean you could you must do this you
people acting like this is a finger you
know it's he's already growing back like
I already got stubble and stuff if I
want to go back I'll grow it back but
you know I kind of like this baby face
look good like it look like I'm 11 and a
half years younger
but then the mustache made me look 11
and a half years maybe the mustache made
me look like 16 years older so now I'm
11 and a half years younger so my like
five years off my regular age over or
under I can't really tell I want to call
some people too though Bob will be doing
that I mean I'm doing some Skype calls I
already talked to a few people you know
get them getting them on the horn find
out what people are doing
I mean I'm personally I'm going
stir-crazy you know it's like it's one
thing like some people are shut-ins
anyway some people love to be at home
and they just don't like to go out but
there's something about having the
option to go out but you decided not to
go out
that's all you but when you at your
place and somebody says to you you
cannot go out now you like looking you
feeling like your place is small even if
it's not small like I don't know what
people are doing in New York like I hear
they're about to put a everybody stay at
home New York I mean a lot of people in
New York you know there's people who
live in like really small apartments
like that's and if you got kids like
what do you do they say you can go out
and jog I saw that like here in LA you
can go out but you have to jog by
yourself so you know it's a jog like I
was going on walks and then you know
I've got my girl here now so it's like
what like if we can't walk together or
people gonna be like hey are we gonna
get ticket so people don't get pulled
over like what is the what's the thing I
just don't want it to get out of hand I
want everybody to like stay calm let's
just see how where it goes
food places are still open you know
they're doing you know the business the
best they can and we're trying to like
help people in terms of like you know
still go out and like help help people
by buying food and you know buying food
from restaurants why it's still there
because this is decimating people's like
livelihood man [ __ ] all my buddies
they're working like food service
they've all been fired which kind of
helped they've been fired by their
employers because they can't pay him cuz
there's no money coming in but at the
same time firing people also helps them
because then they can apply for
unemployment but who knows if that
money's gonna run out cuz how many
people are gonna apply for unemployment
if everybody applies for unemployment do
they have enough money to help people
because
literally everybody is unemployed unless
you like work it like Amazon or Target
or someplace like that that still open a
supermarket but is it enough hours to
stay it's to stay afloat like our
apartment manager is gonna be like
they're gonna be acting like slum Lords
right now are they gonna realize what's
going on right now and give people a
break because everybody's struggling
like I hope that we're gonna find out
you know about society right now when
something with with something like this
we're gonna find out really like do we
love our fellow man are we gonna help
out I mean it's difficult I mean when is
the next time I'm gonna be on the comedy
store stage it's weird to think about
you know the Laugh Factory of the improv
or like go out of ten just what am I
gonna be in front of like you know
hundreds of people thousands you know
for some of these other guys who are
playing theaters and stuff like that
when will the entertainment business
restart concerts and you know like
amusement parks and like all the things
we sort of like take for granted cuz
they're just there and now we're just
sitting here like how important is
entertainment to your everyday life it
seems to be pretty important if you
think about it I mean I don't
some people like don't ever go to
concerts but if you ever go to like one
concert you should I always say to
people make sure you go to you whoever
your favorite artist is when they come
to your town go check them out go check
him out and see because it's like a real
magical experience especially if it's
someone that you really love and admire
even with sports I always regretted
never going to see Michael Jordan play
live when he was at his prime because I
went and saw 55 Wizards or whatever
number he was playing when he was with
the Wizards I wanted to go see that and
it was cool way it was like he's
something electric about the guy right
but there was a part of me that was like
damn I wish I would have seen him when
he was like and his peak like I've seen
Madonna like a couple times I went to go
see Madonna a few years ago and she's
cool Madonna puts on a great show but
dis is like you know almost grandma
Madonna you know she's like in her six
and she's still moving I gotta give it
to her she's doing her thing but I'm
like damn what what was 31 year old
Madonna like on tour was that like was
it she had more energy like how was it
so you know people still great even in
their later years but take advantage
like go see people and now I don't know
when we're gonna be able to do that
again so you know it's man I just hope
everybody out there is staying safe you
know stay safe people I mean it's weird
you know I mean all I've been doing now
is just watching I've been catching up
on a bunch of shows just watching TV you
know I'm just rambling with you guys
right now and that you probably
listening right now this guy's just
rambling I am I'm rambling for you let's
just ramble together I've been watching
shows I've been I watched his show on
HBO The Outsider oh [ __ ] it was spooky
spoiler alert this I won't even talk
about like what happens in the show but
is that I like the pacing you know and
you'll finish it as 10 episodes I don't
know if they're gonna cover another
season but it's a complete when you from
start to finish when you're when it's
done you feel satisfied you feel like
okay that was a cool scary story it's
pretty uh intense you know you know it's
super it's a supernatural thing then you
know so sometimes I like a good balance
between like like this could this could
be real in real life like this is
there's some reality to it and then a
hint at supernatural but there's still a
thought that it could possibly or not so
when I'm watching something if I have
the felt like if you watch a Harry
Potter you know this is all science
fiction it's all fantasy so you wrap
your brain around that you suspend your
disbelief and you're like boom here we
are magic is real it's in my mind I'm in
the world I'll go with the rules but
something like this like you're going
you're going you're going and then you
then it's like there's a moment that it
goes from like oh this is you know
misunderstanding to oh it's magic and
then you have to flip your brain so
that's the only thing that I don't know
if I like that or not but I did enjoy
that show so I do recommend you guys
watch an ass show
and I'm catching up on stuff that I
never watched a lot of like like kyun
peels on Hulu right now right and qiyam
feels so funny to watch on YouTube
because you could just like see the
sketches so you don't even need to watch
episodes because it's just likes cats
cats cats cats cats but I turned to the
show on on Hulu and I've been seeing
some of these sketches that I've been
laughing at on you know on my YouTube
and it's that show is [ __ ] I'm funny
like those two guys Joe key and Peele I
mean I just find myself like like
heartedly laughing like belly laughing
at some of the ideas and sketches and
like the commitment that those two put
into each character I mean it's so great
like it really I recommend like if we
just need to laugh and escape like watch
it on YouTube or if you got Hulu check
out the episodes because they even have
their little funny interstitials like
the last season that I'm watching right
now I think it was the last season they
were like in a car having conversations
and it has such great chemistry and
rapport it's really really great to
watch and then I'm thinking about also
got some think about these movies in the
fever's that uh like we're not gonna be
able to see like we're not if they're
just gonna put movies like directly onto
Netflix so just gonna go like okay or if
they're gonna be like you know like buy
the movie that you know it's okay okay
it's now available on Apple iTunes or
Google whatever and you could like buy
whatever like the Black Widow movie or
like whatever these movies that are
coming out like pour Vin Diesel cuz I
heard this was like a really good movie
from someone so you know I don't think
anyone's ever gonna see it it's just
come and go I don't think they're gonna
be like well let's restart it in the
theaters I mean it's like oh my god just
think about how we've just been living
our lives this is a strange thing about
coronavirus just to reiterate again what
I was talking about before we are living
our lives and all the things that
connect each other even for me like at
the comedy show like you know going to
the comedy club all the people that work
at the comedy club all what it takes to
have like five 600 people at the Comedy
Store at one time 200 something in the
original room 3 400 in the main room
whatever in the in the belly room within
the people that are walking
hallways you know it's like every night
like the last year it was like four to
five hundred people just at that place
every single day and then like all the
servers and and then like you know
people come there then they go home and
they laugh and all the things that are
involved with it is just gone people
that like love to it like I had that AMC
whatever the the a-list where you get to
go to like it's for movies a week or
three movies a week you know they just
they sent a message saying like don't
worry we suspended your account you know
I have my health thing that I was doing
you know I was going to this place
called next health it's in century
cities in Westwood it's great preventive
medicine stuff I'm be upfront honest
some of the stuffs a little pricey but
you know it's about preventive medicine
like I was worried about my own health
because of my mom I didn't want to get
to a certain age and you know not that I
if I if its genetic tanned you know it
is what it is but I wanted to prevent
some of these things like you know work
on the inflammation my testosterone is
way up now my you know my body fat is
down I'm little I'm actually down 25
pounds in body fat if you can believe
that I know I still look fat but I'm
down to body fat so now I got to just
add a solid workout routine that I can
start sculpting my body the way I wanted
to look but I've been doing that by
going to next health I even got a food
sensitivity test and this [ __ ] blew my
[ __ ] mind food sensitivity test like
you wouldn't even believe some of the
things that and that leads to
inflammation at least like your belly
hurting in in fatigue and like you know
a sluggishness and you don't know what
it's coming from because it doesn't hit
you right away so I went to this place I
got this blood test and I came back and
I was like what like I have a food
sensitivity to eggs onions almonds like
two or three kinds of fish seaweed you
know I love sushi there were some things
on there did you go oh I thought that
like brown rice was another one of them
brown rice I have a food sensitivity to
it I was I can't tell [ __ ] out of here
Brown right so so you go out and you
think you're being healthy you're like
yeah give me to see we give me the brown
rice with the almond
give me the almond milk instead of uh
you know okay and none of that [ __ ] I
mean I get coffee's another one like
coffee have a sensitivity to so I
stopped drinking coffee I stopped eating
eggs how does that mean onions because a
lot of the recipes that I get on this
thing that I cook all the food a lot of
the things are onion so I got it going
and like let them know like I can't have
onions and so they could change the
recipes but you know it's it's crazy
like you know you wouldn't even know the
things that you're sensitive to that
could be causing issues you know we we
have this Western medicine idea that
it's like we only go to the doctor when
we're sick you know we think of medicine
and medical as like as a way as the cure
as opposed to prevention and some of
that can be medical medical prevent
prevention is important and some of you
already doing it like exercises medical
prevention you know because it's like
you know the proper diet and that kind
of stuff so for me it's just you know
I'm trying to I'm trying to like get a
regimen sleeping is another one like
sleeping at a certain time and waking up
like having the proper sleep these are
all things that are preventive
techniques to help you be healthier than
long one you know it's like every time I
go in there and I get my my body scan
and I get you know they weigh me you
know it's like yes it's like you know
that's how you fight off cancer and all
these kinds of things that come from you
know we're we're poisoning ourselves
I must leave speak for me i poisoned
myself with just sugar and carbs and all
the things that are so [ __ ] delicious
that we eat all the time so maybe during
this time of coronaviruses time to like
really pay attention to your diet like
I'm still gonna have to go on walks you
know they say you could walk by it you
know you can go by yourself so I'm gonna
have to like go on a walk by myself cuz
I still want to stay active you know
what I mean and I feel like I've slimmed
down a little bit and I think you know
you guys gonna tell me in the comments
you know but it's just weird out here
you know
oh my god wonder whatever what are we
doing guys what are you guys doing out
there let me know in the comments like
how are you managing with your everyday
just everyday life like what are you
doing you know I hope you you know we
should like help each other out with
like exercise techniques you know I was
like going on the internet and going
like YouTube like quick 10-minute
workout like if the internet goes now
it's gonna be anarchy you know what I
mean like like that's the last line of
defense right now of boredom the last
line is like freaking the internet
YouTube Instagram all that stuff that we
keep looking at all that stuff that
keeps us like connected and it's not you
know what's funny is I'm realizing
that's why I was talking about earlier
about calling people and people calling
me who've never called me before it's
weird how we thought we were so
connected you know we thought we were so
connected with our Instagram when our
snapchats and our like you know you talk
to someone and they don't want to oh
don't don't call me you know you can
barely get anybody on the phone nobody
wants to call nobody wants to FaceTime
everybody wants to text they want to be
on their stupid apps and all this stuff
and now once the option of actually
seeing people in person is taken away
now everybody's like yo hey man what's
going on hey what are you doing what's
happening like Bobby has Bobby Lee he's
called me like every single day he just
calls hey man boom boom boom and I'm
like oh this [ __ ] you know it's
like we're just out there bored and
we're thinking about like oh these are
the people that I don't know when I'm
gonna see them again you know and it's
like all my comic friends are like they
were not young you know but we're not
like the the high at-risk age but it's
still like we ain t not 20s and 30s
either you know I would hate to see some
of my good friends like get sick and
then not recover or like or just get
sick and it's one of the the bad the bad
cases cuz some people have gotten like
really sick this is what I'm saying
about the misinformation about it too
like what's going on out there it's like
and this disease this virus is a
[ __ ] because
it doesn't affect children very very
young people right and it seems to be
and then the the healthier people in
their 20s they seem to be recovering
this [ __ ] is attacking people with
immune diseases respiratory problems and
old people it feels like to purge man
just feels like the earth of light used
to many you [ __ ] and let me get
rid of the let me get rid of the weak
let me get the weak and the ones that
don't cherish the time they have here
boom let's hit them with this it feels
it feels spooky because right now
imagine if if it was affecting children
we would have been done with that with
Twitter was to worldwide quarantine we
would have all been inside a month ago
my buddy Craig are from worst fireteam
he was talking about this virus over a
month ago over a month ago we were
online video games and he's just sounded
like a crazy conspiracy theory guy he
was like hey just viruses serious you
know it's gonna get here and you know
everybody was like shut up Craig
well actually should have listened but
you know who knew apparently he knew so
and this is why I like you I don't know
where he was getting his information
from but there is a subsection of
society like these people who are like
online but they're not online shopping
they're not on there they're deep in
they're looking at different news
organizations like finding that other
deep the bloggers and those people those
people the ones they got the real
information out there cuz like every
time every time I turn on CNN every time
I turn on CNN every time I turn on Fox I
don't know what the [ __ ] is going on man
like what is happening on this network
on these networks it's like how could
this how can they both be true how can
they both exist at the same time we're
like they're talking about the same
thing you know I remember back in the
day when like Katrina hit and you have
turn on CNN and they they make you think
that George Bush created Katrina
in a lab you know that's the way they
were talking about it it was like wow
[ __ ] this guy he can't do this he's this
is all his fault
nothing's ready they'ii turn on fox and
it was a completely different that
wasn't even the narrative at all so i
feel like i hope that like the need for
people to stay alive and be together and
and stay healthy overrides this
political divide that has been going on
maybe this is like exactly what we
needed you know in terms of like well
it's never what you need but you know
what i mean in terms of like you know we
need to stop shut everything off and
look look at your fellow neighbors look
at your brothers and sisters look at
your friends your family and be like
okay what is truly important under
saying I hope this [ __ ] don't last long
I hope it don't last long cuz I want to
get out I want to get out I want to work
I mean thank God I'm a frugal
[ __ ] so I got I'm a penny
pincher you know I mean I do some fun
things for myself you know I mean I got
an electric car you know I got the
Clipper tickets but other than that I
stay frugal as hell so I'm be okay for a
few months maybe longer but I know
there's some people out there that are
not you're not gonna survive the way you
think so hopefully you know I heard
Trump talking about some uh some what do
you call this um stimulus packages they
gonna send out to everybody just some
money out there but I don't know if it's
gonna help I don't know if it's gonna be
enough but I guess we're just hoping
upon hoping that this is not gonna last
forever
alright y'all this is a quickie a little
30 minute 30 minute or so rift with
Griffin quarantine special you know I
don't know I've been doing cook I'm
cooking on instagram so follow me on
there I think I'm gonna start taping it
with my good camera and then putting it
on my podcast episodes to like hey look
at this after this a recipe here's some
chicken with something you know I don't
know I just because while I'm inside I'm
trying
make as much content as I want but you
actually send me some ideas too you know
that's someone I want to do Q&A is I
want to like actually talk to fans I
want to get you guys involved I have the
ability that's like I said to tape Skype
calls so I want to start doing that and
look in closing stay safe guys you don't
know if you have it or not the sucky
part about this virus is there's like a
there could be a three to 14-day
incubation period if I hope I'm using
the right terminology it just means that
you could have it and not show any
symptoms for two weeks and then while
you have that symptom while you don't
have symptoms you're also contagious so
yeah you might be young and healthy and
you might have even have gotten it and
already recovered from it who knows I
don't that's another thing that I don't
think everybody has the same level of
sick when they get it you know so we
heard Tom Hanks Tom Hanks got it has he
recovered we haven't even heard about
Tom Hanks I'm telling you we were
teetering right there if Tom Hanks is
super super sick and something happens
to him Oh heaven forbid that's gonna be
the thing that's gonna really shake
everybody if you're not already shaking
up shaking up enough because they just
Kevin Durant
you know the Mitchell from Utah a bunch
of NBA players I said to Lakers they
wouldn't say who but you know so this is
like you know those type of people are
getting it so stay safe you know keep
keep everybody safe think about more
than just yourself and take care of
yourself be healthy love your loved ones
I know it's gonna be challenging out
there right now you know with every
religious Peschel ii if you're in a new
relationship or you or less than three
years and you are cooped up with
somebody you know you are gonna learn a
lot about that relationship trust me
I'm dealing with it right now I'm
learning a lot about my relationship
right now but you know it's it's I think
it's great and a long one that's gonna
be great because you know the Love's
gonna shine through and then we got to
be here for each other through these
trying times so I look at I have good
feelings and I'm sending out my thoughts
and prayers to all the people that
listen to riff Andrew Griffin all your
loved ones all your family members all
your friends and neighbors I wish
all the best and I'm gonna be here
giving you content just like this
sometimes somber like this hopefully
sometimes fun and you know we will see
where we go from here but you know what
I don't normally end like this
but let me give you some more some more
rules and this coronavirus so once again
y'all thanks for listening until your
favorite podcast
[Music]
be safe out there
[Music]